ahsoka's fourth episode of Turner
live-action Star Wars Universe on his
head but what does that huge Cameo mean
for the rest of the series before
delving into the significance of episode
4 of Ahsoka it's important to discuss a
little thing called the world Between
Worlds after all this is one of the
least explored Concepts in the entire
Star Wars franchise so it's important to
lay some groundwork in simplest terms a
world Between Worlds as an ethereal
plane connected to the force where all
points within the Star Wars Universe
timeline meet Ahsoka Creator and general
Star Wars figurehead Dave filoni has
described it as a place where everything
unfolds at once the voices can be heard
echoing throughout time
those voices
where are they coming from but the world
between Wells is not necessarily a means
of time travel in the traditional sense
you can't easily access it and hop
around from Gateway to Gateway as you
please due to its non-linear nature and
the fact that it's highly specific to
whoever has access to it at a given time
individuals are more likely to encounter
something that has a greater connection
to them as opposed to random moments in
time this is exemplified in Star Wars
Rebels when Ezra Bridger enters the
world Between Worlds and discovers a
portal to the last time he saw Ahsoka
alive okay so you know all about the
world Between Worlds all that's possible
to know at least so let's get into that
Cameo bearing in mind today filoni's
comments about how the world between
worlds are somewhat tailored to the
individual it seems only rights to
Anakin Skywalker would appear to Ahsoka
he's arguably the person with whom she
has the strongest connection having
studied under him as a Jedi for years
that's probably not the only reason
Anakin appeared to her so quickly after
her arrival though in addition to Ahsoka
and Anakin close personal connection as
individual beings Anakin is what's known
as a living virgins virgin says also
known as Nexus are specific items places
and people that command high levels of
force energy verse 4 sensitives feel a
particularly close connection to them
after his death Anakin becomes one with
the force making him even more powerful
than he was when he was alive which is
pretty remarkable since he's easily
counted among the most powerful Jedi of
all time therefore it only makes sense
for him to convene with Ahsoka as soon
as she enters the world Between Worlds
operating under the assumption that
Ahsoka is actually meeting with the
spirit of Anakin in the world Between
Worlds there's one big question worth
asking why the obvious conclusion is
that he wants to make amends the last
time he saw her was Anakin they were
just barely beginning to reconnect after
she left the Jedi Order behind the siege
of Mandalore and the Battle of Coruscant
both kicked off soon after separating
them before they could say or they
needed to after so much time apart and
then this happened
foreign
subsequently became Darth Vader and
Ahsoka had no choice but to go into
Exile only years later would she choose
to emerge from the Shadows to help form
the Rebel Alliance while it's nice to
think that Anakin wants to make up for
turning his back on the Jedi and the
Galaxy as a whole there was a more
interesting Theory regarding Anakin's
presence Anakin failed as a teacher to
Ahsoka and he knows it but he still
taught her a lot from battle strategies
to knowing when it's acceptable to bend
the rules for the greater good Anakin no
doubt set her on the path to success and
at this point in time Ahsoka is
struggling to teach Sabine the way of
the Jedi she needs guidance and Anakin
can provide in the world Between Worlds
Anakin can also access key moments from
their time together to help her return
as a mentor Sabine needs her to be of
course it's impossible to discuss the
next chapter of ahsoka's story without
bringing up Darth Vader the Ahsoka
episode Fallen Jedi ends with a snippers
of The Imperial March hinting that
Ahsoka might not only encounter Anakin's
Light Side self or passing through the
world Between Worlds sadly we won't know
how Vader might play a part in the next
few episodes until next week at least
but there are a few ideas that could
lead to Ahsoka meeting him in some
capacity one Theory holds that the
Anakin Ahsoka runs into when she enters
a world Between Worlds isn't actually
his true Force Spirit at all perhaps
he's just a projection of Swords or a
vision that is manifested with ahsoka's
arrival this would mean that it is
capable of presenting itself as his Dark
Side Alter Ego with ease on the other
hand Ahsoka might not come up against a
version of Vader at all rather observing
Anakin's dark Deeds as a Sith through
portals to learn some kind of lesson now
it's also entirely possible that the
craters behind Ahsoka simply included
Vader's theme at the end to grab fans
attention and hearken back to previous
films but it's where's the fun in that
in the events that Ahsoka encounters
Darth Vader and the world Between Worlds
should at least have some idea of what
to expect from a former Masters evil
form as you're probably well aware the
two cross Sabers and one of Star Wars
Rebels most important and emotional
episodes season 2 Twilights of The
Apprentice takes place on the planet
malachor where Darth Vader arrives at a
sith's temple and nearly strikes down
Ezra before Ahsoka steps in to defend
him I need a lot more training
in their first meeting since the end of
the Clone Wars Ahsoka attempts to reason
with Vader who counters by offering her
a place within the Imperial ranks she
turns him down of course the two
exchange blows at the entire Temple
begins to crumble around them and Ezra
makes his Escape meanwhile Ahsoka
invader's brutal fight comes to an
ambiguous conclusion as Ezra watches on
in horror and the episode ends with a
famed Jedi's fate left unknown despite
her bewilderment over Landing in the
world Between Worlds during the events
of Ahsoka it's important to remember
that Ahsoka has indeed stepped foot in
this Timeless void before ahsoka's last
visit took place in the Star Wars Rebels
season 4 episode a world Between Worlds
long after the battle of malachor Ezra
discovers an entrance to the world
between Wells and the Jedi Temple on
lothal Amazed by his Discovery he walks
along a narrow path to investigate the
portals around him one of these hosts a
door between Ahsoka and Vader and in an
effort to save her life Ezra pulls his
friend out of the fight now in the world
Between Worlds Ahsoka teaches Ezra about
the mystery us plane and explains to him
the great power it possesses in the
wrong hands it could be used to rewrite
time and disrupt the natural order of
the universe thus Ezra elects not to go
back and save his master Kane and Jairus
from his tragic demise recognizing that
his sacrifice was essential to save the
lives of others after helping him
narrowly hold off him for a Palpatine
who seeks the world between world's
power for himself Ahsoka returned to her
own time Ahsoka later pops up in the
rebels series finale revealing that she
survived her clash with Vader after all
ahsoka's latest trip to the world
between Wells is already after an
incredible start for Star Wars fans Not
only is that a treat to see Hayden
Christensen back yet again as Anakin
Skywalker but for the first time ever
Anakin and ahsoku have shared the screen
in the world of live action fans have
seen them team up in animation since
2008 and many have wanted to see them do
the same in live action for years now a
long last Star Wars fandom has been
granted His Wish at the same time it
stands to reason that there might be
more in store for ahsoka's Trek across
the world Between Worlds if there's one
thing Dave filoni loves it's throwing
unexpected cameos into his shows and
stories notably the world Between Worlds
seems like the perfect place to deliver
some more looking back on ahsoka's life
there's a great potential for audiences
to witness anything from a meeting with
Captain Rex to a chat with friend turned
enemy Barris offee maybe Ahsoka could
even peek through a portal to a notable
moment with Yoda or Obi-Wan Kenobi
hello there the sky is truly the limit
here but at the end of the day this is
all purely wishful thinking if Anakin is
the only surprise that will between
Wells brings that'd be just fine too
cameos lore and long-awaited live-action
meetings aside you might be wondering
what exactly is next for Ahsoka now that
she has entered the world Between Worlds
it should be pointed out that a strange
and underworldly as it is the world
Between Worlds is not exactly an
afterlife that's not to say that Ahsoka
Has Come away from her fall on cetos
entirely unscathed but something is
indeed very wrong if she has ended up
here with the eye of Scion transporting
thrawn's lackeys to the far-off Galaxy
in which he has hidden for years now
seems as good a time as any to get back
to reality it may seem like it's in
ahsoka's best interest to Simply find a
portal that puts her in the perfect
place to mess up Morgan Elle's best
plans but that's probably not a great
idea doing so could cause a great deal
of disruption to the force and the
universe so Ahsoka will no doubt have to
be careful if she pops back in anywhere
she'll have to do so around the time
she's pushed off the cliff then again
who knows what she got up to between her
visit with Ezra and the world Between
Worlds and her re-emergence in the
rebels finale maybe there's a better way
for her to bring herself back that has
yet to reveal the itself for now we'll
just have to wait and see
foreign